the morning Skyline in leviv in the Far
West it is the part of Ukraine
considered to be the safest
four Russian cruise missiles hit the
city
the Kremlin had said it would Target
critical Ukrainian infrastructure
leviv's mayor said warehouses and a
mechanic Workshop were hit sources have
told us that an aviation repair plant
was the Target and that two of the
missiles were shot down by Ukrainian air
defense
seven were killed 11 injured including
artem just three years old
they had escaped the missiles far to the
east in khakive but not here
what we've seen today in Ukraine is
genocide it's a deliberate action by the
aggressor who are killing peaceful
civilians it looks like the enemy is
committing more atrocities and now
they're smashing civilian infrastructure
we see it in our cities in the east of
Ukraine
and to the east in dinipro
at the military cemetery
the daily burials
[Music]
a family's farewell
a unit's farewell
[Music]
just two weeks ago there was just one
row of graves here
this is one Cemetery in one city in one
region
Andre breslavtsev was 25 years old
it's the scale of the loss and the waste
it really hits you here and the tragedy
is that there is no sign at all of
anything changing quite the opposite
in the besieged city of mariupole the
fighting continues this video posted
today by Ukraine's azov Battalion shows
a counter-offensive there we've located
it to the city but can't verify when it
was filmed the men on the left are
Ukrainian the vehicles are destroyed
on this red van you can see the Russian
Zed symbol
for weeks Russia has claimed it's on the
verge of capturing this key port and
that the ukrainians are all surrounded
in a metal Factory and yet here they
appear actively to be attacking and
flying their own drones
and Ukraine's military spokesman says
it's not the only example of their
forces pushing back the Russian
offensive
I can confirm that following intense
fighting the Ukrainian troops have
liberated a number of populated areas I
cannot give you more information however
I will stress that the towns of isium
and its suburbs these are the areas of
highest concentration of Russian units
it is from there among other places that
they will try to launch that Eastern
offensive
the breadth of this latest Russian
barrage has been remarkable this is
khakive 250 miles north of mariupole 700
miles east of levieve
Ukraine's Second City still being
bombarded eight weeks into this war and
still resisting occupation
[Music]
but here's the cost
the victim
is her father
Mark Stone Sky News in eastern Ukraine